[Music]
there are some new drugs being developed
my favorite
yay
is it by our favorite pfizer is it for
kids
is it pretty good how high will this get
me yes uh because fentanyl is kind of
weak now is it it's not working anymore
of course
dude you take it and you you only just
die now
where's the high before yeah i know what
the hell is that that's a good point it
like sends me to hell you know
[Laughter]
these drugs not heaven
are have the intention of allowing
humans to potentially live up to even
200 years old
off so you spend 100 years in a
retirement home yeah yeah
we we get that nazi dude
to live another hundred years yeah
i'm trying to make him live a little
longer
give me this pill give me one of them
hundred year mortgages my [ __ ]
mortgage is like 20 bucks a month
wow the bank is like why did we do this
look he's like i guess i gotta take the
pill to make the money off this guy
so a british scientist has said that new
drugs that remove
zombie cells in our bodies could let
humans live to the age of two hundred
zombies we knew we had zombie cells i
[ __ ] knew it
what did they do great so this dude dr
dr andrew steele uh andrew steele that's
a cool name it is a sick name he
recently authored a new book on
longevity and has said new advances in
xenolytics analytics i don't know drugs
that focus on the destruction of cells
that degrade tissue function could
extend our lifespans uh he explains i
don't think there's any kind of absolute
cap on how long we can live there should
be though
yeah
probably yeah
depending on your uh your social score
oh
he says studies come out every few years
that propose some kind of fundamental
limit on human lifespan but they're
always missing one crucial piece we've
never tried treating the aging process
before and like i'm assuming he's not
talking about like skin care we've never
thought of that he's talking about like
these deteriorating cells right uh that
pretty much start eating away at your
body which which makes it so it's
difficult to kind or
i guess the best way is it literally
ages you right so he's talking about
this type of drug and go in there and
kill those zombie cells that age you i
wonder what this is what happens into
actual zombies
do we create actual zombies from
this ears don't stop growing what if
you're 200 that's just going to be like
we're going to be like
your ears don't start growing no
cartilage yeah your cartilage keeps
growing your nose gets bigger your ears
get bigger
whoa
i see steve like i was like he's
checking it
nick's nick's 300 years old your numbers
are going to be down here dude
nick's ears grow up between jk news
videos
[Laughter]
dude when i found some pictures of me as
a kid my ears were way too big for my
head really so you grew into it and then
it got big again well they were still
big they were still big as [ __ ]
you're gonna be like dumbo bro we're
gonna be able to fly with you dude
nick's gonna be 200 years like i'm
[ __ ] 200 this is ridiculous
this is way too long
10 years ago
i wasn't hating for 200 years have you
ever considered getting like an ear
reduction or something like that like
like getting plastic surgery to cut it
off because implying something yeah i
know you're the 15th person who told me
that ig handle then i know
nick the proportion
nick the face they can't even pump gas
without people like hey you ever thought
about doing something about your ears
people keep coming up to me hey i have
an idea for you probably hadn't thought
about before
plastic surgery you [ __ ] freak and
then i watched you in mexico too so
i got a buddy who just did that he did
like teeth in mexico it's like a whole
[ __ ] thing yeah nadeem did his
[ __ ] teeth in turkey yeah yeah his
teeth look great you know our uh [ __ ]
eric the cpa
the accountant eric you know ray ray too
yeah yeah yeah you know so many people
yeah albert rachel no after i saw in the
deems then i started to go oh wow a lot
of people actually don't have real teeth
yeah yeah i didn't realize that but
i i can't get over like him hit like
them when they gotta shave it down
that's part of scary i was like
who looked like a [ __ ] great white
shark they put you to sleep though right
no not him he sent a picture for the
[ __ ] from the table or well as long
as they don't [ __ ] hit the nerves
that's just like calcium that they're
just like drilling right still like you
feel pressure but you don't feel pain i
think it's the idea of seeing your teeth
look like
it's also like you you can't get that
back you know so if the veneer goes bad
or whatever you need to get like that
veneer replaced and you don't have well
you're only doing that because the one
you can't get back is already bad right
no it's a lot of it's classic a lot a
lot of people are doing like the full
veneers even though they have perfectly
fine teeth they just want to get
everything like to look perfect like a
[ __ ] photo shop because
i know my friend ray he's wants the
[ __ ] deal and he's like well i might
as well just do this while i'm here
i don't have to come back here get more
teeth muscle get all my [ __ ] teeth
right now
he's costco buying his [ __ ] tv yeah
he is
he didn't even have a cavity it was just
a regular cleanup yeah so what about
that we just uh chopped all these that's
who he is you're right i was like i
never thought of it that way maybe he
only needed like three and he's like
[ __ ] it do it all right i'm not coming
back and he's like i'm gonna get some
ammo on here too
[Laughter]
in mexico that's dude that's his text to
me he's like get my teeth done he's like
man this shit's crazy he's like i just
picked up some ammo
and it will see a video later of his
whole cabinet full of like coffee
that'll last till 20 45 full and then
he's still buying more like three weeks
later yeah it's like great you don't
need any more coffee bro
you just showed me doesn't that go bad
over time too dude i don't think he
knows that
he doesn't even drink coffee
she's hgh you know what i'm saying
so uh like this says um
he points out that the advances uh in
synalytics i don't i [ __ ] don't even
know if i'm pronouncing that senior
lytics senior linux senior linux well he
says i can't see a physical or
biological reason why people couldn't
live to 200 the challenge is whether we
can develop the biomedical science to
make it possible the question is do i
want to live together no i feel like i
feel like everybody will always try to
ask that question of like how but if
you're warren buffett and your life is
[ __ ] sick right sick so sick and
you're just like it's gonna end already
yeah that's true if it wants to i got
some more i got so much more mcdonald's
to eat he might be a bad example though
right because he got like billions of
dollars but he's still driving the same
car live in the same house but his life
is sick he's the same busted-ass white
house thank you
mrs buffett bro come on bro he's
mcdonald's every morning does he every
[ __ ] morning he has his routine man
they did a day in the life that [ __ ] was
tight he went out same [ __ ]
drive-through same [ __ ] order he eats
a [ __ ] that's just for the content
man i don't know i think he gets
if you're warren buffett you're so rich
that you could pay all your friends to
like look better it's like hey dude fix
your [ __ ] face fix your whole head
out of
your stupid [ __ ] head again until you
fix it that's true because his best
friend charlie munger looks like he's
like dead and he came back to life
charlie monger looks like a prison guard
from the nazi working
he looks like
[ __ ] 117 years old dude they're like
geriatric as hell so you're saying that
if you had the opportunity to either die
at 100 or live to 200 you would die at
100. i would live forever but i want
people to die if he's buffett though you
want to be buff you want to see people
die around you no no people just want to
see the world burn and that's the job
i think i think some people should
actually like like it's like it makes
sense why we need a shift in power all
the time right because like old old
ideas need to [ __ ] die out just like
them but then if they're always in power
dude what the [ __ ] so we're never gonna
see change if people live to 200 we'd be
more [ __ ] yes yeah because like
imagine if kim jong [ __ ]
the kim legacy stayed in power forever
and ever and ever right then what is
that definitely what's still happening
that's what they're taught in korea
they're literally
live forever yeah until they die and
then they're like oh sorry they don't
actually this guy didn't live forever
and right now but the next guy who lives
forever yeah they don't poop yeah no
poops
and then they invented the burritos yeah
no poop make burritos yeah dude that guy
wants to live forever buff it you want
to live forever if you're a john or kim
jong oh that too dude i guarantee you
all the [ __ ] top notch people in the
world they all want to live forever
because
wants to live forever i guarantee it
jesus wants to go go down and live in
margaritaville
if you own margaritaville you don't want
to [ __ ] die
yeah have you been to a margaritaville
hell yeah i don't want to die when i go
to margarita bro have you been have you
been to one in vegas yeah i went to walk
through that one so that's the whole
point yeah you do kind of want to die
i'm already drunk once i get there
i'd rather a margaritaville than a fat
tuesday i'll tell you that you know
that's a that's a fact you make a good
point you get a cuban sandwich but you
could probably drown in the fat tuesday
you could like actually like yeah
remember all of us we bought one fat
tuesday none of us could finish it
together
that [ __ ] was as tall as steve did you
guys you guys got extra shots too right
well yeah otherwise you get the sugar
because you know why because it was on
jk we're like get the premium dump it in
there yeah
dump it in there give me that
that top show my bosses are paying
it was like 30 bucks or what i don't
know 18
as we walked on the circus buffet yeah
exactly that buffet wasn't good it was
terrible yeah he's like plastic what are
you trying to say everything tastes like
plastic nothing wasn't a shade of brown
it was really bad so gross oh alex he
recently was in vegas and he goes i
stayed at the circus circle why and i go
how was that hotel is it because he has
an rv and he launched the rv party no no
he goes i asked him how was the hotel he
goes that is the worst hotel i've ever
seen why would anyone stay there i don't
know my family used to stay there a
bunch of kids but back then it was a
different time back then it was dope
then why the [ __ ] did we eat there
because it's funny it was like the way
we used to be like the wind like that
was the
i don't remember when it was that it
might be worse than actually
just walking through there bro
[ __ ] that you take years off your life
just walking through the lobby breathing
so much cigarette [ __ ] and all kinds of
weird smells decades of cigarettes the
guy that's carving the beef i was like
what is that it's like beef or something
it goes something like that
so good she goes why are you here
something like that that's why you can't
go eat that crispy cream i'm going to
use this knife to slip knife to slit my
wrist later like you should probably
leave you sure you want some of those
remember that the ceiling was [ __ ]
leaking as we were walking out the water
was still dripping on top of that booth
and by the way i've never won at circus
circus never no we definitely did not
win that time you don't win at circus
circus bro
yeah that's right i won thirty eight
dollars anthony was my uh crap sifu and
he showed me how to work well i think i
spent thousands at circus circus do you
spend thousands well over time oh and i
never won
in what [ __ ] time you spent thousands
of years
no no that night we went i lost 1230
minutes oh yeah that's also bart's point
bro how you guys lost 300 and like i
gave bart a couple hundred bucks too and
he lost a legend in like under 10
minutes i lost like a hundo and i was
like this is whack and then i was like
hey steve i'm gonna go drink at the bar
yeah i was like this is absolutely
[ __ ] whack and dude let's get doubles
let's go back nothing but curses
suddenly suddenly i'm getting feedings
for no you know where we had a good run
at stratosphere a needle bro
stratosphere we had a [ __ ] and we
were we were on like some [ __ ] craps
table with bad odds heater it wasn't
even like regular oh was it adding
numbers it was like weird oh crap
[Music]
you guys walked out with hundreds and
you're like yeah we [ __ ] showed 100
now [ __ ] we we made hundreds of dollars
at that casino whales bro and then i sat
by my phone waited to get banned i
didn't get paid
oh and didn't they have like dollars
craps or some [ __ ] we were playing with
low ass
[Music]